ya es necesario el pase sanitario para
hacer vida normal y turismo en italia
desde este viernes para ingresar en
bares restaurantes cines gimnasios o
museos es imperativo presentar el
llamado green pass o pase verde un
documento necesario para acreditar la
pauta de vacunación de recuperación de
la enfermedad o un test kobe negativo
reciente en la primera jornada de
vigencia la implementación del pase
sanitario se ha traducido en cierta
confusión tanto para residentes como
para turistas
nos pidieron el paseo solitario algunos
me lo tenían porque todavía no
recibieron la vacuna así que hemos
tomado cosas para llevar estas
para muchos la disposición es bienvenida
como una medida de protección
beneficio del cliente fácil sanitario es
un beneficio para nosotros y al dueño de
restaurantes y para los clientes
y podremos manejar mi misma para de
miami vacunen 6 sigan las normas pidió a
los ciudadanos este viernes el primer
ministro italiano mario draghi muy útil
desde que el gobierno planteó la
imposición del pase sanitario cientos de
personas contestaron la medida en las
calles calificándola de liberticida y
orientada a la práctica a obligar a la
población a vacunarse fue lo que yo
opino lo que opino es esta medida es
necesaria a día de hoy prever un estado
dicha movió seguridad área de betu de
provisión de un estado bio securitario
donde tienes que certificar
continuamente que no estás enfermo es
conforme a un estado de derecho
teniendo en cuenta que con la vacuna
evitamos síntomas graves pero no el
contagio cuál es el sentido del pase
sanitario
a partir del 1 de septiembre el pase
sanitario también será necesario para
usar el transporte público de larga
distancia en los centros educativos será
requerido al personal de educación
obligatoria y superior a estudiantes
universitarios los docentes que no lo
aporten serán suspendidos de actividad y
sueldo